rien n'arrête versailles les hommes de
la cité royale ont remporté une 10e
victoire consécutive ce dimanche 13
janvier leur victime du jour monter son
deuxième du classement les versets ils
ont emporté c'est à 5 mais cette fois ci
à 100 la manière directe c'était très
haché donc il n'y a pas eu
c'était dur oui c'était une équipe en
face qui a ses acquis assez accrocheuse
donc on a eu du mal à mettre notre jeu
en place
après on n'a pas non plus été trop mis
en difficulté en défense
voilà faut se satisfaire de cette
victoire et de les éloigner du bonus
défensif
avec cette victoire les versailles et
compte douze unités d'avancé sur leur
dauphin montesson après dix journées
disputées
même si la montée en fédérale 3 semble
s'est dessiné pour versailles le staff
vont continuer à engranger les points
mais au bout de six sont claires c'est à
dire que nous on veut rien lâcher
on va essayer de gagner tous nos matches
comme on fait tous les tous les
week-ends le but doit être aussi docile
intégré pas mal de joueurs comme on l'a
fait avec des rotations pour tout le
monde puisse goûter la belle aventure
est bien évidemment on veut c'est
d'aller le plus loin possible après pour
continuer cette série d'invincibilité
versé se rendra sur le terrain de
gif-sur-yvette le huitième du classement
le dimanche 20 janvier